ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
ARAMBULA.
BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BURNER FOR BATH.
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES CHAU.
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU [inaudible]
CHOI KANSEN CHU COOLEY.
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
[inaudible]
DALY DEEP. EIGHT MEN FLORA.
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN.
GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GLORIA.
GONZALEZ IS GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE OF KILEY
[inaudible]
LACKEY LEVINE.
LIMON.
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
MEDINA.
MELENDEZ MULLIN MURATSUCHI.
NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US ROBERT
REAVIS.
RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH.
STONE.
TEEN VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON WEBER.
WICKS [inaudible]
WOULD [inaudible]
MISTER SPEAKER
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND OSHA.
REPETITION.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
TODAY WE ARE REMEMBERING THE
RESULTS OF EXECUTIVE ORDER.
NINE ZERO SIX SIX WHICH MADE ME
EVERY MAN WOMAN AND CHILD OF
JAPANESE ANCESTRY REGARDLESS OF
STUDENTS CITIZENSHIP AN ENEMY A
MA'AM.
THIS EXECUTIVE ORDER ARRESTED MY
PARENTS AND GRANDPARENTS.
IN INCARCERATED THEM WITHOUT DUE
PROCESS OF LAW FOR THE DURATION
OF WAR WAR.
TO MY GRANDPARENTS AND MY MOTHER
HAVE PASSED.
MY FATHER WHO WAS DRAFTED FROM
THE CAMP IN JEROME ARKANSAS.
INTO THE ARMY AND SERVED IN
GERMANY AND FRANCE DURING WORLD
WAR.
TWO WILL BE NINETY SEVEN THIS
YEAR.
MY PARENTS.
AND GRANDPARENTS CAME BACK FROM
THE PRISON CAMPS AND MAKE NO
MISTAKE THEY WERE IN EVERY WAY
PRISON CAMPS FOR PEOPLE OF
JAPANESE ANCESTRY.
HE CAME BACK FROM THESE CAMPS.
AND REBUILD THEIR LIVES.
REESTABLISH THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AND INSTILLED IN THEIR CHILDREN
AND GRANDCHILDREN.
A DEEP SENSE OF PRIDE TO BE BOTH
JAPANESE AND AMERICAN.
BUT MOSTLY MOST IMPORTANTLY.
I AM PROUD THAT OUR COUNTRY.
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
IS A NATION THAT ACKNOWLEDGES
MADE.
AND THEN HAVING THIS DAY OF
REMEMBRANCE.
WE ARE TRYING TO ENSURE THAT OUR
COLLECTIVE CIVIL LIBERTIES WERE
NOT BE DISREGARDED AGAIN.
IN OBSERVING THIS DAY OF
REMEMBRANCE.
WE REAFFIRM OUR COMMITMENT AS A
NATION. TO CONTINUE OUR PURSUIT.
OF LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
NUMBER DOWN SU WITH KINDNESS AND
GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND OUR STAFF AT
BLESSING.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
TO REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US
FOR THE FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK SILVA AND SHE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE.
PLEASE JOIN ME TO SALUTE ARE
FLYING.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE --
I YES.
MOVING THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
THURSDAY JANUARY THIRTY FIRST
TWENTY NINETEEN THE ASSEMBLY MET
AT NINE ORIA MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS THAT THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS IN PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE IS A
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED THESE
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
TODAY'S ABSENCES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
MR GLORIA DO YOU HAVE.YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN EIGHT AND TO ALLOW
SPEAKER RENDON.
AND ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MURATSUCHI
AND PETRIE-NORRIS TO HAVE GUESTS
AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR
TODAY.
OFFICIALLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS GAS WILL BE SEATED
WITH HER AT HER DESK.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MESSI GROUSE REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS GLORIA LACKEY
AND MAKE THIS TO SPEAK ON A
GERMAN IN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THINKING ON A SPEAKER.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
IN THE ASSEMBLY TODAY.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS AND GIVE
YOUR ATTENTION AS WE START THOSE
INTRODUCTIONS [inaudible]
RIGHT.
MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
MEMBERS TODAY A RISE TO PRESENT
A RESOLUTION IN RECOGNITION OF
OUR GOOD FRIEND FRIEND VERY
BROAD WHO IS RETIRING.
I AS IS A LOT OF YOU KNOW I COME
FROM -- LONG
LINE OF TEACHERS MY GRANDFATHER
WAS A TEAMSTER MY UNCLE WAS A
TEACHER MY COUSIN.
WAS A TEAMSTER HAVE A CERTAIN --
STEREO TYPE VISION OF WHAT
TEAMSTERS ARE LIKE --
WHEN I FIRST MET?
THOUSAND EIGHT I WAS WORKING ON
BUILDING AT GREEN BLUE ALLIANCE
I WAS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE.
OF CONSERVATION VOTERS.
AND I AM NOT VERY AT A A MEETING
WITH --
LABOR GROUPS AND ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS --
MET SOMEBODY TOLD ME THAT I
WOULD LIKE A SAID HE'S ONE OF
THE MOST INTERESTING PEOPLE
YOU'LL EVER MEET --
AFTER THE MEETING I ASKED VERY --
TO SIT DOWN AND I SAID DO YOU
WANT TO HAVE A BEER I FIGURED
HE'S A TEACHER.
HE SAID I DON'T DRINK --
AND I THOUGHT WELL MAYBE HE'S
THE MOST UNINTERESTING GUY IN
THE WORLD --
AND THEN I SAID YOU WANT TO GO
GET A CUP OF COFFEE SO I'LL HAVE
AN ICE AND ICE TEA --
I THOUGHT HAVE CUTE --
AND THEN BUT WE SAT DOWN WE
TALKED --
FOR TWO HOURS THAT FIRST TIME WE
TALKED OF HE'S A A NOVELIST AS A
LOT OF YOU KNOW WE TALKED A LOT
ABOUT WRITING.
TALKED ABOUT RELIGIOUS FAITH
BERRIES.
VERY -- WE
TALKED TO A LOT ABOUT FAMILY --
WE TALKED --
IT WE TALKED IT WE AN INCREDIBLE
CONVERSATION THAT DAY.
AND THEN EVERY TIME I COME TO
SACRAMENTO WE DO --
WE CHAT MORE AND MORE VERY HAS
THIS INCREDIBLE ABILITY OF TO TO
FIND.
THESE OBSCURE AND ODD CHARACTERS --
IN WORLD HISTORY THAT YOU'VE
NEVER HEARD OF IT I'VE NEVER
HEARD OF AND HE CAN JUST SORT OF
GIVE YOU THESE INCREDIBLE ORAL
DISSERTATIONS ABOUT THESE QUIRKY
QUIRKY INDIVIDUALS --
AND WHAT IS SPECIAL ABOUT BERRY
IS THE FACT THAT.
DESPITE ALL OF HIS INCREDIBLE --
INTELLECTUAL DEATH --
HE STILL HAS --
THE TEAMSTER AND A LOT OF WAYS --
HE HAS HE HAS THAT HEART.
THAT COMMITMENT TO SOCIAL
JUSTICE IF YOU THINK ABOUT HIS
KIDS -- ONE
OF HIS KIDS --
IS -- YOU
COMMITTED --
TO TO TO CONTINUING TO WORK --
FOR WORKERS RIGHTS ANOTHER CHILD
RIGHT NOW IS SERVING IN ISRAEL --
THEY'VE VERY MUCH CONTINUING THE
FAMILY TRADITION THAT BARRY HAS
STARTED.
PEOPLE A VAST IF I'M GONNA MISS
PERRY --
WE'RE I THINK WE'RE HAVING
DINNER.
NEXT TUESDAY SO I'M NOT GONNA
MISS BURIAL OF ME TO CONTINUE TO
SEE VERY BUT I KNOW A LOT OF US
WANT TO THANK HIM FOR ALL OF HIS
EFFORTS WELL HE'S BEEN HERE THIS
BUILDING THANK YOU VERY
.
MR FRAZIER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
MEMBERS I PROBABLY PROBABLY RISE
TO RECOGNIZE COMES IN
CORPORATION.
AND CELEBRATE THEM ON THEIR ONE
HUNDRED YEAR ANNIVERSARY.
CUMMINS THE CORPORATE IS A
GLOBAL HEAVY DUTY POWER TRAIN
AND TECHNOLOGY LEADER WITH
DIESEL.
NATURAL GAS HYBRID AND
ELECTRIFIED PRODUCTS IN BOTH THE
ON AND ON HIGHWAY AND OFF
HIGHWAY MARKET.
CUMMINS WAS FOUNDED IN.
NINETEEN NINETY IN COLUMBUS
INDIANA AND HAS GROWN
SUBSTANTIALLY NOW OPERATING IN A
HUNDRED AND NINETY COUNTRIES AND
EMPLOYING MORE THAN. FIFTY EIGHT
THOUSAND PEOPLE WORLDWIDE.
IN CALIFORNIA COMING EMPLOYER
EMPLOYS MORE THAN SIX HUNDRED
PEOPLE.
INCLUDING TWO HUNDRED CERTIFIED
CUMMINS TRAINED TECHNICIANS.
THE POWERS MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES.
PROVIDES CRITICAL PRIME IN BACK
UP POWER FOR FACILITIES AND
BUSINESSES.
AND POWERS MORE THAN 90%.
OF THE TRANSIT BUSES
[inaudible]
IN CALIFORNIA.
COME IS HELPING CALIFORNIA
MUSEUM VICIOUS AIR QUALITY GOALS
BY REDUCING ITS PRODUCTS IN
BUYER MIDDLE IMPACTS.
BEING IN THE FOREFRONT OF POWER
TRAIN INNOVATION INVENTING NEW
TECHNOLOGIES IN THE HEAVY DUTY
MARKET.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
WELCOMING GREAT L. INJURE.
PRESIDENT PACIFIC REGION RICK
CAM VICE PRESIDENT OF SALES
PACIFIC REGION.
TOM SWENSON REGIONAL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT MANAGER CALIFORNIA.
AND JEAN BAPTISTE GALLO PRODUCT
MANAGER.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE THEM A WARM
WELCOME IN A ROUND OF APPLAUSE
TO COMMEMORATE THE ONE HUNDREDTH
YEAR AND AS ANNIVERSARY COME AS
A CORPORATE UP IN THE GALLERY.
MEMBERS LET'S DIRECTOR ATTENTION
TO MISS PETRIE-NORRIS WHO IS
RECOGNIZED FOR HER INTRODUCTION
TODAY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING TO THE FLOOR TWO VERY
SPECIAL GUESTS MIGHT FIND DILLON.
AND HATE IN OUR JOINING US TODAY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REAVIS.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
IT'S EXCITING FOR ME TO ANNOUNCE
THAT THIS WEEK WE CELEBRATE
ENGINEERS WEEK.
THERE MORE THAN TWO MILLION
ACTIVE IN LICENSE ENGINEERS IN
THE U. S. WITH ALMOST A HUNDRED
THOUSAND OF THEM PRACTICING IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ENGINEERS APPLY THEIR UNIQUE
SKILLS AND KNOWLEDGE TO ALMOST
EVERY ASPECT OF OUR LIVES FROM
ENSURING THE AIR WE BREATHE.
IS SAFE TO THE BRIDGES WE CROSS
OUR SECURE.
AS AN ENGINEER MYSELF.
ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUES FROM
HEY WORD AND BIG BEAR LAKE WE
ARE EXCITED TO RECOGNIZE AND
HONOR THE GREAT WORK ENGINEERS
BRING TO OUR STATE.
SOME OF WHICH ARE HERE WITH US
TODAY --
THREE PLEASE GIVE A WARM WELCOME
TO AMERICAN SOCIETY OF CIVIL
ENGINEERS REGION NINE DIRECTOR
KWAME ATARI.
THE PRESIDENT AND VICE PRESIDENT
OF THE STRUCTURAL ENGINEERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA CHOICE
BUS AND BEAR IN THEIR CLUB.
THE BY.
THE VICE PRESIDENT AND
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE CO CHAIR
OF THE AMERICAN COUNCIL OF
ENGINEERING COMPANIES KERR YOSHI
AND JANE ROSCOE.
ALONG WITH JESSE --
GUIDI SECRETARY OF ACC
CALIFORNIA'S LOS ANGELES CHAPTER.
THE PRESIDENT ELECT AND VICE
PRESIDENT OF COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING OF PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS IN CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT JOE MELLO AND MATT
HANSON THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
AND WELCOME.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REQUESTS MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE IN INTRODUCED SOME
STUDENTS WE HAVE HERE TODAY FROM
THE HAMLIN SCHOOL IN SAN
FRANCISCO WERE VISITING OUR
CHAMBERS.
AND I LIKE TO RECOGNIZING
INTRODUCED MEMBERS FROM THE
AMERICAN INSTITUTE OF
PARLIAMENTARIANS THERE SEATED IN
THE GALLERY THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE FOR OUR ASSEMBLY
FLOOR SESSION.
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE ASSEMBLY
JOINT RESOLUTION.
ONE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO VIETNAMESE REFUGEES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAILY MAIL BEEN.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ELEVEN YEARS AGO THE
UNITED STATES IN VIETNAM AGREED
TO PROHIBIT THE DEPORTATION OF
VIETNAMESE AMERICANS.
WHO ARRIVED IN THE US AS
REFUGEES PRIOR TO JULY?
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE THIS
RESOLUTION CALLS IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO STOP ANY EFFORT TO
CHANGE THAT AGREEMENT.
WHICH COULD DRAMATICALLY
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
VIETNAMESE AMERICANS DEPORTED
BACK TO VIETNAM.
THE SENATE HAS ADOPTED THIS
RESOLUTION THEIR AMENDMENTS WERE
NON SUBSTANTIVE.
THE MEASURE HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND NO I WILL OF PRE
SHAKE YOUR AYE VOTE.
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE WE WILL OPEN THE ROLE FOR
CONCURRENCE ON THIS MEASURE.
ALL MEMBERS WHO DESIRE VOTE
PLEASE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS WHO DESIRED --
ALL THOSE WHO DESIRED --
PLEASE VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
TALLY THE VOTE.
AYES FIFTY FOUR NO ZERO
CONCURRENT PASSES.
SINCE SENATE AMENDMENTS
CONCURRED WITH.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWO RESOLUTION.
TWELVE MISTER MURATSUCHI YOU MAY
OPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM SPEAKER.
NO.
THE CLERK WILL READ SORRY MISS
MESSAGING.
AS ON THE CURRENT RESOLUTION
TWELVE BY SOME THE MEMBER MERCY
CHEAP RELATIVE TO A DAY OF
REMEMBRANCE.
NOW YOU MAY OPEN MISERERE CG
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
I RISE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION. TWELVE TO
DECLARE TODAY AS A DAY OF
REMEMBRANCE THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
EXACTLY SEVENTY SEVEN YEARS AGO.
ON FEBRUARY NINETEENTH OF
NINETEEN FORTY TWO PRESIDENT
FRANKLIN ROOSEVELT SIGNED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER.
THAT LED TO THE MASSING BECAUSE
SERRATION OF OVER ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND JAPANESE
AMERICANS BASED SOLELY AND
EXPLICITLY ON THEIR RACE WITHOUT
ANY DUE PROCESS OF LAW.
AND WITHOUT ANY EVIDENCE OF
TREASON FOR MILITARY NECESSITY.
THEY WERE INCARCERATED BEHIND
BARBED WIRES BASED ON THE CLAIM
THAT ALL JAPANESE AMERICANS ON
THE WEST COAST POSED A NATIONAL
SECURITY THREAT.
IN.
NINETEEN NINETY NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT PRESIDENT RONALD REAGAN.
SET THE RECORD STRAIGHT BY
SIGNING A HISTORIC CIVIL RIGHTS
BILL WHICH PROVIDED REDRESS TO
SURVIVORS.
AND WHICH DECLARED THAT THE
JAPANESE AMERICAN INCARCERATION
WAS IN FACT CAUSED BY RACIAL
PREJUDICE.
WARTIME HYSTERIA.
AND A FAILURE OF POLITICAL
LEADERSHIP.
WOW THIS TRAGIC CHAPTER IN OUR
NATION'S HISTORY OF TODAY WIDELY
CONDEMNED.
BY MAINSTREAM AMERICA
[inaudible]
RECENT ACTIONS.
TAKEN BY PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP.
HAVE RATES GREAT DOUBT ABOUT
WHETHER WE AS AMERICANS HAVE
REALLY LEARN THE LESSONS OF THE
JAPANESE AMERICAN WARTIME
INCARCERATION.
JUST LAST YEAR EIGHTY IN THE
UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
DECISION.
OF TRUMP VERSUS THE STATE OF
HAWAII.
THE CONSERVATIVE MAJORITY UP
HELD THE CONSTITUTIONALITY.
OF MR TRUMP'S MUSLIM TRAVEL BAN.
IN A SCATHING DISSENT TO THE
MAJORITY OPINION.
JUSTICE SONIA SO TO MY AUTO.
JOINED BY JUSTICE RUTH BADER
GINSBURG.
CRITICIZED THE MAJORITY FOR
DEFERRING TO THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S CLAIM.
OF A QUOTE ILL DEFINED NATIONAL
SECURITY THREAT. TO JUSTIFY AN
EXCLUSIONARY POLICY OF SWEEPING
PROPORTION.
RELYING ON STEREOTYPES ABOUT
MUSLIMS AMID STRONG EVIDENCE
THAT IMPERMISSIBLE HOSTILITY AND
ANIMALS MOTIVATED THE
GOVERNMENT'S POLICY.
AND JUST THIS PAST WEEK.
MR TRUMP DECLARED A NATIONAL
SECURITY CRISIS ON OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
I'M THE RATIONALE THAT CENTRAL
AMERICAN MIGRANTS INCLUDING MANY
FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN SEEKING
REFUGEE AND ASYLUM THE STATUS.
POSE.
A NATIONAL SECURITY THREAT.
WELL MR TRUMP.
CALLS THIS AN INVASION.
BUT THIS IS NOT PEARL HARBOR.
THIS IS NOT THE PERSIAN GULF WAR.
AND THIS IS NOT.
NINE ELEVEN AND WE STAND UP TO
UPHOLD AND DEFEND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES.
THE LESSON TO REMEMBER FROM THE
JAPANESE BURKE IN WARTIME
INCARCERATION.
IS THAT WE MUST BE CONSTANTLY
VIGILANT AGAINST THE ABUSE OF
POWER BY THE EXECUTIVE OR ANY
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT ESPECIALLY
UNDER THE GUISE OF NATIONAL
SECURITY.
WE MUST NEVER FORGET AND THAT IS
WHY I ASK YOU TO JOIN ME AND
COMMEMORATING.
THIS DAY IN HISTORY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI ASSEMBLY MEMBER RE
THIS YEAR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TO SUPPORT ACR TWELVE DECLARING
FEBRUARY NINETEENTH AS A DAY OF
REMEMBRANCE TO RECOGNIZE THE
INCARCERATION OF JAPANESE
AMERICANS DURING WORLD WAR.
TWO THE TUNA CANYON DETENTION
CENTER IN MY DISTRICT WAS
OPERATED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND DETAINED OVER TWO
THOUSAND MEN WOMEN AND CHILDREN.
OF JAPANESE ANCESTRY.
ALTHOUGH THIS DETENTION CENTER.
IS NO LONGER STANDING IT AND UP
AND REMEMBER THE STORIES THAT
TOOK PLACE DURING THIS TERRIBLE
PERIOD OF OUR HISTORY SO THAT WE
REMEMBER NEVER TO REPEAT IT.
I COMMEND MY COLLEAGUE FROM
TORRANCE FOR AUTHORING THIS
RESOLUTION AND I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER US.
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THE FIRST
ROLE TO BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI WE
WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON ACR TWELVE
FOR CO AUTHORS.
FIRST BILL IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ALL MEMBERS ARE DESIRED ABOUT
PLEASE VOTE THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE CO AUTHORS.
WE HAVE. FIFTY EIGHT CO AUTHORS
ON ACR.
TWELVE WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON ACR.
TWELVE ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE
[inaudible]
ALL OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION PASSES.
IN THE ABSENCE OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR INTRODUCTION THANK YOU
AGAIN MADAM SPEAKER WE HAVE.
A SEVERAL IMPORTANT GAS JOINING
US IN THE BACK OF CHAMBERS TO
RECOGNIZE I JOIN US TODAY IN
THIS DAY OF REMEMBRANCE.
PLEASE FIRST OF ALL WELCOME
KAREN KOREMATSU THE FOUNDER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE FRED
KOREMATSU INSTITUTE.
AND THE DAUGHTER OF THE LATE
FRED KOREMATSU.
KAREN HAS BEEN CARRYING ON THE
SCORE MATZ'S LEGACY AS A CIVIL
RIGHTS LEADER AND EDUCATED
EDUCATOR SPEAKING OUT ON SOCIAL
JUSTICE ISSUES THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY.
WE'RE ALSO JOINED.
BY PRISCILLA CHEETAH.
FORMER NATIONAL DIRECTOR OF THE
JAPANESE AMERICAN CITIZENS
LEAGUE.
AND ALSO A FORMER LONGTIME
STAFFER IN THIS BUILDING HAVING
SERVED AS CHIEF OF STAFF TO
SENATORS PATRICK JOHNSTON.
AND JOSEPH MILLION.
WE ARE ALSO JOINED BY STAN --
MEHTA AND CRISTINA MADE UP
CHAPTERS OF THE JAPANESE
AMERICAN CITIZENS LEAGUE.
STAND WAS INCARCERATED AT THE
JEROME AND HE LOWER RIVER CAMPS
AND CRISTINA MEADOW WAS
INCARCERATED.
AT THE TOLL PASSED INTO LEE LAKE.
CAMPUS ALSO WHAT THIS IS KATIE
OR MORE OFTEN THE SACRAMENTO
CHASE HE'LL AND JANICE YAMAOKA
LUSAKA ALSO FROM THE SECOND OKAY
SO PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
ALL OF THESE.
WONDERFUL GAS
.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS.
THE QUORUM CALL IS NOT LIFTED.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
FOR ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY GIVE
YOU RESPECTFUL ATTENTION TO YOUR
COLLEAGUES PLEASE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
MR GLORIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
THIS AFTERNOON TO ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF WORLD
RENOWNED EXPLORE AND SCIENTISTS.
WATERMARK.
WHAT AMOUNT WAS BORN OCTOBER
NINETEENTH NINETEEN SEVENTEEN IN
VIENNA AUSTRIA TO THE FAN OF
FAMILY OF PROMINENT BANKERS?
HE SOON REALIZES MORE BASE TO
REALIZE HE WAS MORE PASSIONATE
ABOUT SCHEME THAT ABOUT HIS
STUDIES.
AS A RESULT HIS PARENTS IN THE
COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY TO BEGIN A
CAREER IN FINANCE.
HE NEVER MUCH NEVER TOOK THE
BANKING THAT JUST WASN'T HIS
THING HE LATER MOVED TO THE WEST
COAST TO CALIFORNIA TO STUDY.
PHYSICS AT THE UNIVERSITY AT THE
INSTITUTE AND CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTE OF TECHNOLOGY.
LATER AS A GRADUATE STUDENT AT
THE SCRIPPS INSTITUTE OF
OCEANOGRAPHY IN THE WHOLE AREA
IN THE SEVENTY THE ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT.
AMONG DISCOVERED A PASSION IN A
WONDER FOR THE OCEAN THE RESULT
IN A LIFE LONG LOVE AFFAIR.
HIS CONTRIBUTIONS TO SIR
FORECASTING AND HIS WORK TO
REFINE THESE PREDICTIONS
PROVIDED THE ALLIED FORCES IN
WORLD WAR TWO THE STRATEGIC
ADVANTAGE THAT THEY NEEDED. TO
CRITICALLY LAND TROOPS ON THE
BEACHES ON D. DAY.
AFTER THE WAR HE DEVELOPED
TSUNAMI EARLY WARNING DETECTION
TECHNOLOGY IT IS STILL USED TO
THIS DAY FOR WHICH WE ALL
BENEFIT.
HE DESIGNED AND LED RESEARCH
EXPEDITIONS THAT HELP US BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE ROLE OF THE
OCEANS AND CURRENTS.
WAS AMONG THE FIRST SCIENTIST
YOU SCUBA DIVING EQUIPMENT TO
CONDUCT HIS RESEARCH.
MARK WAS INSTRUMENTAL AND
SUCCESSFULLY LOBBYING FOR THE
CREATION OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA CAMPUS NOW LOCATED IN
SAN DIEGO.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE HE WAS
HONORED WITH THE PRESIDENT'S
NATIONAL MEDAL OF SCIENCE FOR
HIS LIFETIME ACHIEVEMENT IN
SCIENCE RESEARCH HE WAS THE
FIRST OCEANOGRAPHER TO EVER
RECEIVE THE KYOTO PRIZE IN BASIC
SCIENCES IN.
NINETEEN NINETY NINE IN TWO
THOUSAND ONE YOU RECEIVE THE
PRINCE ALBERT METAL IN PHYSICAL
SCIENCES OF THE OCEAN IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN HE RECEIVED HIS
FAVORITE HONOR.
THE EXPLORES METAL.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN HE WAS
AWARDED THE FRENCH LEGION OF
HONOR THE HIGHEST FRENCH
DECORATION GIVEN TO CIVILIANS OR
MEMBERS OF THE MILITARY.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN I HAD THE
HONOR OF PRESENTING DOCTOR MONK
WITHIN ASSEMBLY RESOLUTION AND
ON THE OCCASION OF HIS ONE
HUNDREDTH BIRTHDAY.
AS WELL AS WILL BE ABLE TO
ASSIST THE CITY AN UNVEILING A
SIGN.
DEDICATING THE LAWYER SHORES
BOARDWALK WAY THIS IS NOT FAR
FROM WHERE HE DID HIS WORLD
RENOWNED RESEARCH.
SADLY NOT AMONG PASSED AWAY ON
FEBRUARY EIGHTH AT HIS HOME IN
THE WHOLE AREA HE WAS A HUNDRED
AND ONE YEARS OLD.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE AND
MY FRIEND MERRY COAKLEY MONTH.
HIS DAUGHTER'S ET IN KENDALL
MONK IN A THREE GRANDSONS WALTER
LUCIENNE AND MAXWELL. TO KNOW
DOCTOR MONK WAS TO KNOW A LEGEND.
WE ARE SO MUCH BETTER BECAUSE HE
SERVED BECAUSE HE WILL LIVE IN
OUR COMMUNITY.
WE WILL MISS HIM GREATLY HE WAS
OUR EINSTEIN OF THE OCEAN.
GOD SPEED DOCTOR MARK WE
JOURNALISM WE TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA.
MEMBER PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO MISTER MATHIS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
YES THE WE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY.
FOR JIM TATUM.
WHO PASSED AWAY ON JANUARY?
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY NINETEEN A
LIFETIME BISHOP RESIDENT JIM WAS
AN INCREDIBLE HUSBAND.
FATHER BROTHER FRIEND AND
COMMUNITY CONTRIBUTOR.
HE GRADUATED FROM BISHOP UNION
HIGH SCHOOL IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN AND WENT
ON TO PLAY FOOTBALL AND BASEBALL
AT ANTELOPE VALLEY JUNIOR
COLLEGE WHERE HE MET HIS WIFE
DONNA.
HE EARNED HIS BACHELOR'S AND
FINANCE FROM CSU CHICO.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO BEFORE
RETURNING TO BISHOP TO HELP ON
THE FAMILY RANCH AND LATER RACES
KIDS.
KELSEY AND KEY.
JIM'S LOVE OF THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY WAS EVIDENT AND ALL OF
HIS PROFESSIONAL AND PERSONAL
ENDEAVORS.
WHERE HE ALWAYS WENT ABOVE AND
BEYOND TO DO FOR OTHERS?
IS A COMPLIMENT [inaudible]
HIS ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
WHERE NUMEROUS ACROSS HIS CAREER?
AS A RANCHER IN HIS TWENTY YEAR
TENURE AS THE CEO OF THE TRI
COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS.
AS THE INYO COUNTY DEPUTY PUBLIC
WORKS DIRECTOR.
AND MOST RECENTLY AS THE BISHOP
CITY [inaudible]
ADMINISTRATOR.
HIS GENERAL.
RACE.
AN MAKE IT HAPPENS PERIOD.
COULD ALSO BE SEEN IN HIS ROLES.
WAS A BISHOP LITTLE LEAGUE AND
BISHOP UNION HIGH SCHOOL
BASEBALL COACH.
A MEMBER OF THE LOCAL SCHOOL
BOARD.
AND THE BELOVED TRACTOR MAN.
THAT THE CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL
RODEO STATE FINALS AND OTHER
FAIR ARENA AFFECTS.
HE WAS ALSO KNOWN. FOR HIS WITTY
AND PLAYFUL SENSE OF HUMOR.
OPTIMISTIC ATTITUDE GREEN PHAM.
AND THAT UNMISTAKABLE WHISTLE
WHILE HE WALKED.
HIS IMPACT ON THE COMMUNITY.
WILL BE AND DURING.
BUT HIS PRESENCE WILL BE SORELY
MISSED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS MISTER
LACKEY RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
TODAY IT IS A GREAT HONOR.
THEN I GET TO PRESENT THE NAME.
OF SERGEANT PATRICIA PAT MURRAY.
SHE WAS A DISTINGUISHED WORLD
WAR TWO VETERAN.
WHO PEACEFULLY PASSED AWAY THIS
FEBRUARY FOURTH?
SHE TOO WAS A HUNDRED ONE YEARS
OLD.
I ONE OF THE MOST LOVED A
RENOWNED MEMBERS AROUND LOW
VALLEY COMMUNITY.
FROM INSTALLING FLAGPOLES AND
PROMINENT PUBLIC PLACES. TO
RUNNING THE AB TOYS FOR TOTS
PROGRAM.
PAT WILL BE REMEMBERED AS A
BEACON OF HOPE FOR THE
UNDERSERVED.
AN A PROUD REPRESENTATIVE OF OUR
COUNTRY.
SHE KNEW WHAT IT MEANT TO BE A
MARINE.
A TRILLION BONDED THE FULLNESS.
OF THE TITLE VETERANS.
PAT INSPIRED COMMUNITY MEMBERS
OF ALL AGES TO REACH BEYOND WHAT
SOCIETY TOLD THEM THEY COULD DO.
AND INTO THE REALM OF WHAT THEY
SHOULD DO.
BY WORKING WITH YOUNG MARINES.
AND VETERAN ADVOCACY GROUPS
ALIKE.
SHE WILL BE REMEMBERED FOR
FIGHTING SPIRIT.
HER LOVE OF COUNTRY.
UNDER NEVERENDING PURSUIT FOR
JUSTICE FOR VETERANS.
SORRY TO PATRICIA MARIE SPIRIT
LIVES ON THROUGH HER TO SEE HER
TWO SONS.
DâN MIKE WHO TELLER STORY.
WITH THE REVERENCE IT DESERVES.
I ASK YOU JOIN ME IN A
JOURNEYING IN HER MEMORY.
THAT WE REMEMBER OUR VETERANS
EVERY DAY FOR THEIR COUNTLESS
SACRIFICES.
THANK YOU MISTER LACKEY.
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
TO THE DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUESTS TO JOURNEY
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE IS PASSED
AND RETAINS.
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS.
MEMBERS I'M EXCITED TO ANNOUNCE
THAT HARTLEY JAMES CALDERON WAS
BORN THIS PAST THURSDAY ON
FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH.
AT SEVEN POINT ONE POUNDS IN
NINETEEN INCHES CONGRADULATIONS
OUR COLLEAGUE MISTER CALDERON
AND HIS WHOLE FAMILY.
THERE WILL BE AN API LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS RECEPTION FOR THE DAY OF
REMEMBRANCE AND ACR TWELVE UPON
ADJOURNMENTS A SESSION.
WILL BE HELD IN MISTER
MURATSUCHI IS OFFICE ROOM TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE JOIN HIM.
MEMBERS THE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS
WILL BE HELD UPON ADJOURNMENT IN
THE SESSION LOUNGE.
THIS SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS.
WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY TWENTIETH
CHECK IN SESSION THURSDAY
FEBRUARY TWENTY FIRST FLOOR
SESSION AT NINE AM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED IN RETAINS ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER GLORIA MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY
FEBRUARY TWENTY FIRST AT NINE AM